Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Imaginez la scène suivante :
vous rentrez de soirée,
il est un peu tard,
vous avez un petit peu bu,
vous êtes un peu éméché,
mais il vous faut rentrer chez vous,
donc vous prenez la voiture.
Il commence à pleuvoir,
à y avoir des nuages,
voire du brouillard, un orage éclate.
Il y a énormément de pluie,
vous mettez les essuie-glaces.
Il commence à y avoir de la buée.
Vous essayez d’enlever la buée
avec votre manche,
mais vous ne voyez pas
très bien devant vous.
Mais ce n’est pas très grave
puisque vous êtes dans une voiture
autonome : la voiture conduit toute seule
jusqu’à chez vous.
En fait, vous le savez, vous avez
assez confiance en votre voiture,
si bien que vous somnolez
un petit peu au volant.
Mais tout à coup, au moment
de traverser un pont, à environ 50 km/h,
deux enfants traversent
la chaussée en courant.
La voiture n'a pas le temps de s'arrêter.
Elle le sait.
Elle peut soit continuer
et renverser deux enfants,
soit se jeter par-dessus le pont
et, potentiellement, sacrifier votre vie.
Que pensez-vous
que la voiture devrait faire ?
Comment devrait-elle être programmée
pour réagir dans cette situation ?
Qui pense que la voiture
doit continuer son chemin ?
Qui pense qu’elle doit
se jeter par-dessus le pont ?
Ce genre de questions est en fait très
classique en philosophie morale
et a été étudié depuis des années, des
décennies, des siècles, des millénaires,
par toutes sortes de philosophes moraux.
C’est le problème du trolley.
Dans cette version très classique,
un trolley ne peut pas s’arrêter.
S’il poursuit son chemin,
cinq personnes risquent de mourir.
Vous avez la main sur un levier
capable de détourner le trolley
pour ne causer qu’un seul décès.
Que feriez-vous dans cette situation ?
Que pensez-vous qu’il serait
éthique de faire ?
Qui pense qu’il ne faut rien faire ?
Qui pense qu’il faut actionner le levier ?
Nickel !
Pas énormément de désaccords.
Ceci dit, en philosophie morale, ce
problème, et toutes sortes de variantes,
ont créé énormément de désaccords
entre les philosophes moraux.
Il y a énormément de littérature
fascinante à lire à ce sujet,
de la déontologie d’Emmanuel Kant
à l’utilitarisme de Jeremy Bentham,
en passant par l’éthique de la vertu
de Socrate, Platon, Aristote
et plein d’autres
philosophies morales encore.
En fait, il semble y avoir presque une
philosophie morale par philosophe moral.
Et c’est assez embêtant.
C’est assez embêtant si l’on veut
programmer, définir une morale,
pour les voitures autonomes.
Mais dans un même temps,
ce n’est pas si grave
qu’il y ait des désaccords
sur ce problème précis
parce que finalement,
le problème du trolley,
ce n’est quand même pas un problème
qu’on rencontre tous les jours.
La dernière fois que j’ai eu la main
sur un levier pour détourner un train,
c'était probablement dans un rêve.
Et puis, même le cas
des voitures autonomes,
ce ne sera pas un cas si fréquent.
Ce sera même assez rare,
et en particulier le problème
de l’éthique des voitures autonomes
réside probablement - et même
très certainement - ailleurs.
L’éthique des voitures autonomes aura
certainement beaucoup plus à voir
avec la sécurité de ces voitures,
le nombre de décès
qu’elles pourraient causer par an,
et peut-être aussi la sécurité
informatique de ces voitures autonomes.
Le risque, par exemple, qu’elles
pourraient se faire hacker.
En fait, s’il y a une chose que j’aimerais
que vous reteniez aujourd’hui,
plus encore que quelque chose d’incroyable
que je vais dire dans 5 minutes,
c’est le fait que les dilemmes éthiques
des algorithmes d’intelligence
artificielle modernes,
ce ne sont pas des histoires
de voitures autonomes ou de robots.
Les plus gros dilemmes éthiques,
ceux qui influencent
énormément notre société,
ce sont les algorithmes qui,
plusieurs milliards de fois par jour,
vont envoyer des messages personnalisés
à chacun des milliards
d’utilisateurs de ces téléphones.
A chaque fois que vous appuyez
sur l’application YouTube,
l’application Tweeter, Facebook,
Instagram ou Tik-Tok sur votre téléphone,
un algorithme d’intelligence artificielle
extrêmement sophistiqué
combine des choses comme le traitement
du langage, l’analyse d’images,
et va sélectionner, à travers
l’immensité des réseaux sociaux,
le contenu à vous montrer.
Bien souvent, ce ne seront pas
des questions de vie ou de mort,
mais même si un pour mille, des milliers,
des millions, des milliards,
voire des milliers
de milliards de recommandations
que font ces algorithmes par jour,
si seulement une pour 1000 est
une question de vie ou de mort,
on a là beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup
plus de dilemmes éthiques à résoudre
qu’il n’y en a jamais eu dans
l’histoire de l’humanité auparavant.
À chaque fois qu’un utilisateur cherche
« la vaccination tue » sur YouTube,
l’algorithme de YouTube doit déterminer,
parmi l’ensemble de toutes les vidéos,
quelle est la vidéo à recommander
à cet utilisateur.
Est-ce qu’il faudra lui montrer une vidéo
parlant du décès d’une personne vaccinée ?
qui parlera des effets secondaires
des vaccins ?
Faudra-t-il lui montrer une vidéo qui
explique le fonctionnement des vaccins,
qui parle de l’efficacité des vaccins,
qui parle de la manière dont
les tests du vaccin ont été effectués,
du suivi des personnes vaccinées depuis,
des conséquences d’une vaccination
de masse sur l’immunité de groupe ?
Quelle vidéo
dans tout Internet, dans tout YouTube,
faut-il recommander en premier ?
Si un de vos amis vous posait
cette question
et que vous deviez recommander
une vidéo dans tout YouTube,
quelle est la vidéo
que vous recommanderiez ?
Tels sont les dilemmes auxquels
les algorithmes les plus influents
et les plus sophistiqués d’aujourd’hui
sont confrontés
des milliers de milliards
de fois par jour.
Et chaque jour compte.
Quand il s’agit
des algorithmes de recommandations,
chaque jour où une solution
n’est pas trouvée
pour identifier les vidéos
qu’il faudrait recommander,
ce seront des problèmes de santé
publique de très grande échelle
qui se poseront.
On l’a vu avec la pandémie Covid-19 :
la mésinformation propagée
par ces algorithmes de recommandation
a des conséquences majeures,
non seulement sur les personnes
victimes de cette mésinformation,
mais aussi et surtout
sur toute la société,
y compris ceux qui n’utilisent pas
ces algorithmes de recommandation.
Si en septembre prochain, on pourra
tranquillement revenir à une vie normale,
ou non,
ça dépendra en grande partie du
succès de la vaccination de masse,
qui dépendra en grande partie
de l’information
à laquelle des millions de nos concitoyens
seront exposés à longueur de journée,
qui dépendra elle-même
en grande partie de l’information
que les algorithmes de recommandation
recommanderont.
Quand il s’agit de santé publique,
quand il s’agit de problèmes
comme le tabagisme ou l’obésité,
comme la santé mentale,
les recommandations de ces algorithmes
ont une influence énorme.
Et chaque jour compte.
Chaque jour sans une solution
est un jour de plus
où ces algorithmes mettent en danger
des millions de vies sur Terre.
La même problématique se pose
pour d’autres enjeux,
comme les enjeux environnementaux.
Comme on le sait,
on assiste en ce moment
à un changement climatique.
Et des mesures doivent
être urgemment prises
pour réduire les risques pour des
millions, voire des centaines de millions,
voire des milliards d’humains
dans les décennies à venir.
Là encore, chaque jour passé
où la désinformation sur ces sujets est
encore promue sur les réseaux sociaux,
où l’information de qualité
sur ces sujets est noyée
dans un océan d’informations
de moindre importance,
c’est un jour de plus
où l’on prend du retard
sur les mesures qu’il aurait
déjà fallu avoir prises
pour réduire les risques
liés à l’environnement.
Chaque jour qui passe
où ces algorithmes continuent
à propager de la haine
et de la désinformation sur des sujets
comme les inégalités sociales,
c’est un jour de plus où ces inégalités
sociales ne reçoivent pas les traitements
et les interventions
qu’elles devraient avoir.
Chaque jour compte.
Quand il s’agit de l’éthique
de l’information, chaque jour compte.
Mais,
il n’y a pas que cette échelle
de temps à considérer.
Une autre échelle de temps
sur laquelle j’aimerais vous amener,
c’est celle des algorithmes eux-mêmes.
Cette échelle de temps, c’est l’échelle
de temps de la milliseconde.
Pour un algorithme,
la milliseconde compte.
Le cas assez évident est celui
des voitures autonomes.
Entre le moment où elles perçoivent
le danger
et le moment où elles doivent réagir,
ces voitures autonomes n’auront pas
le temps de lire l’intégralité d’Aristote
et de Platon.
Ces algorithmes devront
prendre une décision
en quelques millisecondes seulement.
Le même problème se pose
pour les algorithmes
les plus influents d’aujourd’hui,
à savoir les algorithmes sur nos
téléphones et sur nos ordinateurs,
parce que les utilisateurs de YouTube,
Facebook et compagnie
sont très impatients.
Il leur faut une réponse
en quelques millisecondes seulement.
Ça, ça veut dire que si on veut résoudre
l’éthique de l’information en général,
il va falloir raisonner
avec des outils algorithmiques.
Et il va falloir
que ces algorithmes incluent
des considérations
philosophiques et morales.
Autrement dit, dès aujourd’hui,
il va falloir combiner,
si on veut préparer
le futur de l’humanité,
l’expertise des philosophes,
des sociologues et des psychologues
avec l’expertise que vous apprenez ici
à l’École Centrale Supélec,
en particulier des considérations comme
la théorie de la complexité algorithmique,
ou encore la théorie
des systèmes répartis,
pour pouvoir fournir des réponses
qui correspondent aux considérations
philosophiques et éthiques des philosophes
mais qui sont également capables
de répondre à des requêtes
de milliards d’utilisateurs
en quelques millisecondes seulement.
Telle est l'ampleur de l'enjeu
de l'éthique des algorithmes.